[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want get out hey
alex
what's up man
you know
alex and nick and gilbert got a mma
podcast
how did you three me gilbert yeah so
just like how i met you guys yeah
training yeah just training he brought
gilbert one day would you say most of
your friends are through the fight world
yeah out here in california because when
i moved out here i only knew my mom and
then my aunt uncle so you're originally
not from here i'm from arizona you came
here to fight
no oh i came here to rap
actually really yeah i was a rapper back
in there but some should go don't don't
was go go go
good that show
but now i came here not some slow jams
just like on a week's notice i decided
to move out here because my mom moved
out here because she works at the
hospital and then
uh then i started powerlifting and got
into powerlifting and then i met a
couple friends through there and then i
started training i met this guy and then
that's when i met all you guys you know
what i'm saying but yeah gilbert i met
gilbert through him he came to one of
the trainings where we would all show up
on the front we were training gilbert
and then he was like hey
he wanted to grab alex and said hey
let's do an mma podcast and i was like
what what happened was because we were
playing video games with uh bobby lee a
lot so it would be me gilbert
and like i always just say like we out
here and then like one day we're all
training and then gilbert kept saying it
and then he was like hey we're gonna
start a mma show called we out here in
mma what did you guys play with bobby
we played call of duty warzone oh yeah
bobby loves gaming yeah we play dude me
we used to play for like eight hours
straight like every day like in the
beginning of the
shutdown because i had no work to do all
the gyms were shut down so i wasn't
training any clients or anything like
that so
me him gilbert would play um and then
bobby started playing with us so he used
to be like all right i know bobby wakes
up by like three
send me send me an invite like at four
and then we'll play until like 11 or 12
and that was every single day for like
three months oh yeah
good now oh it was fun it was over hella
good do i play power game you ever play
pirate game
no fire games sick what's pirate game
yeah [ __ ] sea at these dude
you're a pirate
oh i think i've seen people play that
you're a pirate sail the high seas you
[ __ ] steal i love that [ __ ] you get
to like you get to like like destroy
other people's ships you mean rape
pillage and plunder that we were asking
about
like gta but for pirates damn they
should do that dude you can help people
i hump people the whole time and i said
i go i sneak on people's ships and i
just randomly set that [ __ ] on fire
or i start to um
fill their boat slowly with water well
you could do all this stuff yeah [ __ ]
yeah if they're very if they're all on
an island i'll [ __ ] be filling
buckets and putting it in their [ __ ]
boat until i sink that [ __ ] how
long how many buckets does it take
forever bro it takes for food
hopefully it already has a hole in it
and then i can just go in there and keep
on showing you can't take a musket and
shoot the bottom of it or something i
wish i don't think it works i've never
tried it got a corkscrew how do you get
a hole in the face i never tried to buy
the [ __ ] dumping buckets forever
you've got to shoot it with the simple
solution just sure
shoot the boat with the can you can
shoot you can use the cannon to shoot
your own sails and [ __ ] dude it's
[ __ ] sick oh you should jump on the
boat take the cannon and shoot the
bottom of the boat that's a sick idea i
don't know if you can turn them oh
do you get it
you get a peg leg and stuff uh you do
get a piglet you got like a a parrot
oh i wanna is it like an open world game
like when you get close to somebody you
can hear them talking yep yeah so those
games are i think it's time for jk to
start streaming video games let's play
the [ __ ] pirate game bro come down i
love pirates oh my god it'd be so sick
we have our own crew yeah what's your
crew what do you have how many people
could be your pirates jk
yeah that's a good that's a good pirate
i think you can have a [ __ ] ton of
people i don't know i don't know though
i don't know the cap i never had that
many that'd be dope if we built like a
whole pirate army
let's go and we just raid people yeah
bro i'm trying to put holes in people's
boats i'm trying to just [ __ ] kill
people by bucket
drowning yeah but imagine if us and the
fan base get together and we just we
could drown
ships with buckets easily yeah dude we
get like 20 of us steve doesn't have to
like [ __ ] do ten thousand bucket
things by himself it's so boring
but i'm laughing so hard
he's out there they're like stop
i'll do the best is when you start with
a crew too this is actually really dick
move but um you start with a crew and
then you start fire bombing your own
ship
blow it up and everyone's like hey [ __ ]
you bro this is a theme that steve talks
about when he's when he's talking about
playing video games he likes attacking
his own crew sometimes
well no but the key is that you got a
role play you got a role he's role
playing so you're like
hey guys like i think we should go this
way um there's some really interesting
treasures in this in this little area
and they're like no we got to go where
the mission is the mission says this and
i'm like i really think that we should
go after the rubies
are you are you on a comp system i'm on
the conversation and then i'm like it's
a [ __ ] mute today
all that [ __ ] dude
is this a computer game yeah [ __ ] yeah
well it's on xbox dude but it's on
computer too okay so it's like and you
can play with if you're on peter you can
play with ugly oh really can you google
this can i see it yeah i want to see
this i think i've seen i've seen people
play it but i've only ever watched like
just little clips you don't play that
lame ass pirate [ __ ] no warzone got
addicting for a while like that's all
our whole entire life by the way um
small tangent does anyone here have a
plug to get a decently priced
playstation 5 actually i might i've been
googling every yeah that might how much
is how much are one of those
[ __ ] minimum is reselling like
900 plus but like they should be out
like 500 bucks if you meet so if you
know or have friends that work at like
best buy or target or anything like that
they get like drops yeah like like 50 at
a time but they will only sell it within
like you know the employees yeah or
people that they know or that's this is
what i've heard so because they're all
sold out yeah i don't know man just make
sony make more playstations bro like
what's going on there's a chip short
it's a ship shorter so so you so you
know somebody that knows somebody that
knows somebody yeah i might know i will
talk let's watch this [ __ ] oh this looks
dope bro right i'm in the water looks
sick too this looks like something i
would have loved
dude dude this [ __ ] again
me too exactly yeah i had a [ __ ] sega
genesis pirates game it wasn't nothing
like this
it was that monkey island i honestly saw
this but i never knew what it was called
so i never tried to play it
you could steal the ship like gta yep
you steal all people's [ __ ] you steal
their [ __ ] bananas and [ __ ] the
bananas they're bananas they're rubies
oh yeah
it's like rust right it's like an open
world open world you can grade people
is there story mode on this because i
like story you can play stories steve
what else do you play besides this i'm
curious the game is you bro this is
about it homie i play this one i play
any game you can [ __ ] people's whole
life
but you say you're a bigger gta right oh
yeah i played gta but i had to give it
up dude i got two into like
role-playing right oh yeah [ __ ] yeah i
would all play with like little a little
british kids and be like your little
[ __ ] i'ma [ __ ] your mom
[Laughter]
so again this is what i want to know if
you play gta what kind of antics would
you carry out oh bro rocket launchers
all day long bro blow people up i can't
too i can't [ __ ]
i'm such a camper i'll [ __ ] [ __ ] up i
will just hang out outside of the gun
store and wait for [ __ ] to walk out
and then once you spawn outside the gun
store i blow you up with a [ __ ]
rocket
and you know what i'll wait there and
one time there was a guy who pissed me
off because he bumped into my car and
like flipped me over whatever and he
killed me and then i tracked him down
the gun store and i waited after that
gun for like two hours i'm not even
[ __ ] around either i just sat there i
put on a podcast and i was like i'm
gonna wait for this [ __ ]
and once he caught out i [ __ ] killed
him yeah i bet he was so mad people get
so mad at that [ __ ] oh dude i'm so
[ __ ] pretty i can't even begin to
tell you
i know a kid who in the game he's an
owner of a chicken store and literally
that's all like his whole entire plane
will play for eight hours he's just
inside of that restaurant he's actually
serving and working i'm like really this
is what you want to do in this video
that's what they do
eight hours i mean he could actually get
a job at popeyes or something you know
what i mean no but then he's gotta
really work you know people play cops
and they're like actually out arresting
people i don't know there's thieves
there's all that it's it's pretty
intense holy [ __ ]
crazy i did a video on my youtube
channel where i got i was getting people
popping people for violating traffic
laws and [ __ ] yeah and i was like you
pull the [ __ ] over right now dude we
were about to have a situation
it was a blast and then you actually
have to go to jail and you're in there
for like 30 minutes or something like
that right i don't remember yeah like
people go to actual jail and you have to
just sit there in the game in the cell
phone
yeah that's hilarious
that's advanced man because i remember
playing oh man story mode that was fun
and then when it went online that was
fun and then i could get an apartment
get girlfriends whatever i got a
girlfriend don't worry about it dude
[Laughter]
you could role play a relationship in
there yeah
and [ __ ] yeah
i know but you could go to the you could
go to the strip club and then pick up
girls when i was a kid and graduate
that's what i did all the time
see them [ __ ] on screen see him [ __ ]
big time dude you get lap dance or
you're just in a car in the car shaking
around it's not your little little kid
game that you probably like yeah [ __ ]
raw dog in it this guy's playing paw
patrol are you serious people people
role playing just [ __ ] each other in the
game you can throw people on the ground
and start [ __ ] their mouths yeah
it's crazy
especially on pc like there's so much to
do on pc
you got to get the update though
how can you do more on pc i think it's
just like the coding like people you can
be like king kong throughout your whole
entire thing and that's gta in grand
theft auto you could be king kong
driving a car around [ __ ] yeah there's
people that do all this crazy throwing
people on the floor and [ __ ] them in
their mouth like king kong how do you do
that for break but i have a [ __ ]
batmobile okay not even bragging i have
a batmobile and if a hot chick gets in
my car i do treat her like she's my
girlfriend
[Laughter]
it would be someone that's like across
the world but you're actually talking to
them because you're close to them in the
game so you can hear their microphone
and they hear use the whole ecosystem
that is [ __ ] crazy that's too much
man i don't think i can handle that i
don't think i can i don't have the
attention span you should get out of my
car i'm like i miss you you got to get
back in the car
i miss you sweetie
did you guys ever get into saints row no
it's like gta but you can run a gang two
joes all about running a gang i'm
telling you bro we gotta do this pirate
ship game yeah we're gonna play power
game dude big time we gotta play pirate
games sail the [ __ ] seven seas bro
have a cutlass
and a [ __ ] six shooter you know
even tiger you could play you can yeah
he's not too dumb
all kinds of dumb kids are on that game
dude bro all kinds of different kids
bro kids nowadays i'm sure they're so
advanced with like video games yeah
probably and all that stuff i bet tycho
can learn how to play that like when
he's five you probably smoke us man yeah
exactly well game what games you guys
played where you [ __ ] like it's so
pissed off like you throw the controller
man i choked the [ __ ] out of my friend
for uh mario kart
he kept talking [ __ ] i just threw the
controller started choking him like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how old are
you 36 37
9th grade oh yeah that's about right
call of duty does that for me he's he's
heard it i can't play with alex anymore
because he gets too mad like like car
rage or like road rage
he's like rubbing his face he's like
[ __ ] i'm getting hot bro he's
competitive bro what gets you pissed off
in war zone yeah it's because you're
like you [ __ ] do everything for like
an hour you lit everybody and then you
just get shot at the end you get killed
by some campers or cheaters a bunch of
hackers that's why i can't play warzone
that [ __ ] would piss me off too much
i'll be camping that whole [ __ ] time
dude
i remember playing a modern warfare and
then like i was like every single time i
spawn man in three seconds i get shot
and i'm like [ __ ] this is hard that's
how i felt like in counter-strike
already that's why i think i never
really got into games because i just
didn't get [ __ ] killed which is why
you just did it for real for real i love
counter-strike i only got into games
over quarantine i never played video
games
this is a recent thing for you have you
played no counter strike dude no my
cousins used to play it all the time
though but i never i was never able to
get into especially
mouse and key games it's fun though you
could do like man people just [ __ ]
memorize you like pc or controller pc
now so i do play on mouse
i do like i like this you get you could
get more [ __ ] like intricate with
this you stream still yeah here and
there i haven't streamed that much
because my [ __ ] internet out of my
house being
no you know all about that but the
spectrum it's [ __ ] spectacular
[ __ ]
i think we do actually have spectrum but
everybody has a spectrum dude
there's like 20 people that live in the
house that i live in so that and the
bandwidth is all taken yeah bro it's
it's insane that's crazy i feel like i
got held into video games during
quarantine as well just had time for it
finally to like sit down and try like an
rpg what did you play uh like i
everybody kept on telling me to play uh
my my girl did everybody kept on telling
me to play god of war four
because then they're like and you would
love this because i love the cinematic
[ __ ]
and that game is the most beautiful
[ __ ] amazing game i've ever played
really it is it's so [ __ ] good it's
like really really really really really
[ __ ] good damn bro and then uh
because because it was uh cinematically
it won't hello awards too uh and
cinematically it's it's a pretty much an
rpg that's constructed in one shot
so like even when it transitions between
your fighting third person to story mode
uh and it like just goes into the
cinematic cuts and stuff it's all in a
one shot and it's like really [ __ ]
beautiful but that's a game that i
started throwing my controller around a
lot because i was so invested
and there's one [ __ ] at the end who's
harder than the actual final story blast
she's just like a side character boss
she's [ __ ] queen valkyrie queen of
the valkyries
i had to youtube so many ways to learn
technique that's like it was real dude
you know what i mean you know when
you're like getting so close to beat
somebody you have to keep on youtubing
[ __ ] like little kids or whooping
fools ass little kids from like germany
or some [ __ ] that just have every
technique [ __ ] russian kids bro yeah
they're so good and then like any time
you get like almost close to beating
somebody and then they whoop your ass
out of nowhere and like two hits
you just feel so like a [ __ ] so you
throw your your controller and stuff
that's why you just watch walk-throughs
that's what i do now tell you i just
watch walk-throughs and then like if
they're doing some [ __ ] where they got a
farm or whatever and they have to like
get points i just fast forward it and i
can go watch what the story does i can
watch how they beat the boss so you
didn't play
no no [ __ ] that another game that would
do that was the ufc game
oh yeah because like you'd be beating
the [ __ ] out of somebody and then they
just throw like one punch and they knock
you out
obviously fall like a second potato like
i remember me and him played and that
was very competitive wait how come they
can knock you out on one punch if you've
been beating their ass it's so random
because like if you like slip into their
kick you know they try to make it more
realistic
yeah dude that's why they [ __ ] madden
up i'm like bro if i can't just throw a
touch on every [ __ ] play this game
sucks ass it's too real i play shotgun
every single time
hail marriott i do four downs every
[ __ ] time i don't care if i'm 30
yards away from the first time the nfl
blitz was the best football game still
of all time and 2k bro 2k was tight too
that still got real for me nfl blitz is
where i was at where you could do like
giant heads and stuff i don't know i
remember that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was so
funny dude nba jam was the [ __ ] nba jam
steal the [ __ ] still the [ __ ] all those
games on computer now you can download
all those
oh yeah all those old school games
dude i saw nba jam i was at a costco and
they had a [ __ ] nba jam arcade
cabinet and i was like what the [ __ ] it
was like 500 bucks you know i have an
arcade cabinet it has like 2 500 games
on it cost us like four grand it was
like you have one yeah the kindreds do
it was like such a waste of money
like super high level of regret for like
years but like we still have it but it's
cool but does anybody play it anymore
yes yeah it has everything i like
scarred myself one time like in a street
fighter tournament because like i'm just
not good at it so i button hella hard
and then suddenly i rip my skin off your
paper spin on there right
there on there everything's on every
tech like every turtle order right next
to it when it's ready you don't even
need to because we could just go free
it's just unlimited credits we should do
a tournament one day let me ask you oh i
[ __ ] love that first of all four
players so you can play like the
simpsons or ninja turtles with four
people
wait how many controllers are there oh
four it's like a giant arcade
the one that was in every single pizza
hut yup dude that one's dope that's not
a waste of money dude let's go play
right now [ __ ] every metal slug every
metal slug every bubble bobble puzzle
fighter let's order pizza pizza hut and
why and play [ __ ] ninja turtles yes
it's at the road right now it's like
tennessee do it yeah let's just let's
just [ __ ] end this [ __ ] we're gonna
go kid just pulling a david right now
this is what david wood did
gets excited about the ideas every
[ __ ] game name the game we have it
[ __ ] raid in [ __ ] is it a full-on
like station full-on it's cool you got
hyperspin hyperspin has everything on
there but i bet it's hyperspin it's
hyperspace
those ninja turtle games are so fun
growing up they're the best dudes
turtles in time too those yeah
can you sit down it has the seats too
well i have stools
no because i didn't know how crazy it is
you know some of those arcades they got
[ __ ] built-in speakers no no it's not
like that no that wouldn't have been
four thousand that would be way more oh
that way he was like what's the big
[ __ ] boy huh yeah it's like a real
regular arcade machine it's not like a
dinky half size it's like a plus size
four still have a connect to guys that
can get arcade [ __ ] cause we're trying
to build an arcade room in our house are
you yeah yeah really trying to they sell
them like at best buy and stuff no you
want you want like i want one that's
like at the liquor store like that kind
of [ __ ] because what they do nowadays is
they just buy a tv and then they build
the frame and then they have the
computer it's a computer with a tv and
then the framing and the control what
about the print on the side i want the
printer the print on the side so we
custom that as well and that took a long
time and a lot of money so you have to
actually have somebody design that so
yours says kinjaz on the
pick a side
i don't know where we're here i don't
even know what we're standing for yeah
all we do i say jabbawockee sucks and
you get all weird now yeah he says jab
and you just roll your eyes yeah you're
like
like you please move on yeah yeah yeah
you get all weird about it so now we
need to meet ninja turtles real quick
bro can we please do that it's a friday
right now holy [ __ ] i'm never gonna tell
you teenage mutant ninja how does that
game work i'm gonna play that you never
played tmnt you're watching
sideways yeah i play street fighter it's
like double dragon
remember that game double dragon double
dragon as well and we also have the ogx
men's know what you could be [ __ ] i
like that one was this like x-men and
street fighter that one no that's that's
like marvel vs captain we have all that
too but i'm story mode yeah the og x-men
where you could be like nightcrawler and
[ __ ] damn [ __ ] juggernaut and [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] memories dude yeah i got
all that stuff
it is really really fun dude our old
video games are so much better than
these video games today dude not the
power game dude [ __ ] that
i'm gonna download this today you should
bro when you do when you sink a ship
you're like whoa that thing went down
and these guys are [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude the best is that they're all
scrambling around in the water and
you're like yeah you're [ __ ] they're
like swimming in the water they can't
get out huh
they drown friggin idiots do you sink to
or you have a little safety blade you're
swimming away well hopefully i'm in the
other boat that the one that blew him
hopefully i'm in the other boat kills
himself too he's like blow up someone
say your boat gets blown up yeah what
happens afterwards so if you have like a
little you get you get the little rescue
boat or whatever and the one that
captain hook's on when the crocodile's
after him you get one of those and then
it that's what survives the ship and
then they can flow they have to buy
another boat no you just wait and then
every one respawns for you somewhere
yeah sick bro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you